first off we got Ariana Grande
international pop star upcoming Star of
the new movie Wicked and she's playing
freaking Glinda all right then we got
Ethan Slater pretty massive theater dude
he's the star of Broadway's SpongeBob
SquarePants he's also in the wicked
movie I think he's playing an Oompa
Loompa so up until recently Ariana was
married to this La luxury real estate
agent Dalton Gomez and up until even
more recently eth was married for four
years to his high school sweetheart Lily
J and they just had a baby boy now I
want to speculate here but it sounds
like he took a trip to her bikini bottom
and slapped some Krabby Patties on her
ass with a side of tartar sauce if you
know what I'm saying Daddy now the real
hog Jam in all of this is that Lily J
SpongeBob's ex stuck with this dude
through the early theater years which is
serious Commitment if you ask me and
then once he hits it big he's all like
thank you next it's like not cool leaf
and not to throw shade on Ariana because
she's cranked out some bangers in the
past few years but it kind of seems like
she likes to Bone dudes in relationships
which I think is reference in the pretty
subtle song title break up with your
girlfriend on board which if you really
look into it has a hidden meaning there